salve youtubers benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione
che come avete detto dal titolo sarà di
videogiochi
premetto subito che la faro' molto molto
velocemente perché e diciamo per
coprire il buco che c è immette sul
concorso
perchè su detto che
teoricamente faccio un video la
settimana
porsche ha fatto una settimana dalla
dall'inizio il concorso faccio un video
poi arrivi tu subito fino alla fine del
concorso
e tra l'altro porca miseria quanti siete
veramente non pensavo
perché il concorso da maltempo arrivati
a
10 9 10 11 adesso siamo già 22 23
calcolatrice
mi hanno fatto sapere che arriveranno
quindi
sarà veramente difficile del previsto
mi sono dimenticato prima di iniziare
una foto karaoke
trucco toledo questa parte che faccio
ooo sempre consigliato qualche anno
qualche utente qualche canale che ho
pubblicizzato qualche canale
quindi
bho continuo a fare così anche se non
ho un vero e proprio motivo per
pubblicizzare quel canale lo fanno
per perchè mi piace una cosa di
collaborazione un po' come dicevo
guastaa11 e' una cosa di collaborazione
tra utenti modà scambiarci
iscrizioni amicizie c'è che mi sembra
una gran bella cosa quindi
i cani via dm
aia di saronno
lo spero si dica così
e' una ragazza che recensisce manga
ci sono tantissimi
utenti che recensiscono manga veramente
tantissime ryanair ieri sono un secondo
me perché una delle migliori perché è
una ragazza
lincol canale
iscrivetevi perchè secondo me ne vale
la pena
allora ora iniziamo subito
scusate se la fanno oh come molto primo
molto velocemente quindi non metterne
anche immagini di gioco
perchè
non se non c'è tutto un po' montare
volevo metterlo giù gioci video 2
perchè
nelle cose che devo dire su questi
giochi
lo sanno bene di uscita trovare e quelle
parti di video quindi
la faccio così hi5 recensire sono
giochi
e acquisto giocando in questo momento
veramente molto
online
e sono 3
le for the wedding
queste grande taglio
modern warfer 2
ovviamente
word of worcraft
allora partiamo con te
le folder
nel fondo
le for the end per chi non lo conosce
egli è uno sparatutto in prima persona
con il sistema grafico un discusso di
alfa x2
qui ubi
più belli che abbia mai fatto per
adesso perchè il più versatile il più
veloce quello che parte anche su
computer vecchi
e se il computer non riavrò un impatto
grafico molto molto buono degli altri
disoccupazione è semplicissimo ci sono
4 sopravvissuti
ehm
credevo molto lontane.
lavare abito - veramente in famiglia
abbia
hey jude diviso in 4 campania
&lt ogni campagne diviso in cinque
livelli 4 5 livelli
perimetro livello consiste nell'andare
da una stanza sicura all'altra con
iphoto sopravvissuti
ovviamente il cuore di joe quello online
giocando da solo è veramente inutile
dopo oltre alle orde di zombie
normalità, ti ci sono 4 tipi di zombi
speciali
1 il vero
che incubi e sogni classico sottopeso
pino di bolle
c'è anche
qua nell'immagine
kia contabilità speciale quella di
vomitare sui sopravvissuti
il vomito
quelle gli sopravvissuti che vengono
ricoperti questo movimento, assaliti da
orde di zombie
lo scopre
key quelli fette speciale che
può piegare la lingua lunghissima
afferrare un sopravvissuto di impiccalo
finché qualcuno non lo libera
lanterna e'una
non so che è speciale incappucciato che
appena come abilitare usb saltare
addosso a un sopravvissuto e massacrarlo
finché qualcuno non lo libera
e il tempio
forse quello più utile
che eu
consumo gigantesco un bestione tipo hulk
che carina.
tira le cuoia gli oggetti scaraventare
tutti ad una vita
lunghissima e.e terminare praticamente
le foto in una partita
il culo come detto prima di questo
quello con la riga
e in particolare la modalità versus
dove 8 giocatori si sfidano 4 fanno i
sopravvissuti
e4a 1
fallo ora
indirizzo mi speciali
c'è attorno nel senso che
possono esserci tutti e quattro insieme
ma dopo ogni giocatore. può farlo o
non so come speciale un altro dipenderà
da quello che sta succedendo in pratica
e quindi
per connetterti mappa in questa
modalità
si gioca a 2 ruote
la squadra una volta fa i sopravvissuti
e l'altra gli zombie e tu ci si
scambiano quando finisce la partita
e a s e finisce la campagna ei chi ha
più punti vince teoricamente
e' bellissima cosa stupenda questo gioco
e' questo il gioco che ti preoccupi
giocando di più in assoluto di questi
tre
solo che
come tutti questi gioki 3 cc non ci sono
delle cose che mi fanno incazzare massa
morire
il resto del presepio
la cosa principale di questo gioco gia'
bitri la coordinazione tre giocatori
quindi
leggi fantasy the 4 survival mode 4
zombie speciali devono essere ci devono
collaborare devo attaccare insieme
oppure quando riparte il culo gigantesco
demo coordinarsi circondato spararli
un sacco di cose del mondo pubbliche
amici cantante cosa
15 la cordinazione ma purtroppo ogni
tanto ci sta
ad interim partita con di giocatori che
okok ho appena iniziati non sono
assolutamente nulla
perchè purtroppo qua
non c è il mondo si sale di livello non
ce la classifica dei giocatori bravi
youtube - qua
le partite sono composte da giocatore
che ci giocavo a 4 anni giocatori che
special lo hanno appena installato
cooper
e allora punkreas di
posso materassi casini
la collaborazione tutto in questo gioco
e purtroppo a volte non c'è c'è ci
sono giorni che non sanno giocare quindi
caso quando sei un sopravvissuto album
allo sbaraglio da solo mentre tutti gli
altri
no perchè se quello che penso testo
ballata per computer mi dice finita
se qualcuno loro ridarella tropo
massacrare uccidere
e si cucina la moneta adesso sono un po'
anche rinascere fino alla mappa.
un'altra cosa che mi è che che ci fa
perché io gioco con le cuffie che la
cosa migliore giocare con le cuffie con
qualcun'altro
mediaset in 4 mai risolto b ci sono
esposte ovunque gioco
atlanta cosa che ci fa incazzare e is on
line circuit
non so se sapete cosa vuol dire ce
è un termine davvero pioppo con tutto
questo vi do comunque
è un termine da nerd reggi twitter che
vuol dire
non è un plus componevano polar rice
twitter twitter vuol dire andarsene
uscire dalla partita
reich e pulire la coppia
ercp che sarebbero usciti dalla partita
per la rabbia quando ti amo anche la
partita sta andando male te ne vai
ma è una cosa sbagliatissima da fare
perchè
quando si creano i quattro spade
sull'ascorbato sopravvissuti
teoricamente tu dopo
2 mappe inizia a conoscere bene sai come
gioca sito come vestivano male
ti conviene comunque comunque vada si
bene o male
di arrivare alla fine con questi altri
due giocatori fucsia tipo tre giocatori
occt che se la partita va male se ne va
lo so perchè puoi
magari non arriva nessuno è 3 4
sopravvissuti c'è un bottone c'è uno
un un sopravvissuto controllato dal
computer fisso
fa schifissimo ma veramente striscio
oppure ancora peggio
dalla parte degli zombi speciali se
sembra che uno non si è incazzato dalla
sua finchè non intorno ad un giocatore
quindi se se sei su 4 se ne vanno via
due rimangono due persone in due non
riescono a fare niente come se tu fossi
4 pere
avere possibilità di vincere come le
trombe
e ci gente che se ne va
ma tu da sola ma perché te ne devi
andare a metà partita che senso ha
se tu sei laura se tu stai facendo
colato squadra se ne vanno via gli altri
perché tu la tua squadra è troppo
forte la squadra save, se ne vanno via
loro e allora devi aspettare che
arrivano altri giocatori oppure vai
avanti ma non ha senso se non ci sono
gli altri
oppure se tu stai perdendo ebay
i sogni comprende la tua squadra che se
ne vanno
quindi in tutti i casi c'è sempre
qualcuno che se ne va
e non ha senso giocare perchè purtroppo
formentera campagna
cv 9a l'amore mezza cenone poco per una
partita online
e tanto però e questo giochi questo
bellissimo gioco la collaborazione now
c'è gente che se ne va
sempre sempre sempre filippo tv
solutions
questo gioco fantastico
purtroppo dono l'ho preso perchè c'è
questo l'ho preso da fuoco
non è mai capitato che ce l'ho
e il 2 uscito adesso quindi
c'è adesso uscito da un pò però
e' uscito tipo in contemporanea questo
perché il tempo brutto colpo.
l'altro giorno che voglio recensire
motivo per cui
premettendo che io sono un fan sfegatato
di mondo il volo di icaro chiudi in
generale
e mi piacciono tutti i giochi l'unico
che non ho provato il terzo ma il terzo
perché uno non è fatto dalla infinity
word shelter attori veri e propri
e tu perchè mi sembra ci sono
abbastanza sicuro
non vorrei sbagliarmi che per pc non
riuscito
il lettere arezzo
è uscito su un percorso quindi
io ci ho giocato al primo secondo
oh mother moster 1 e modern warfer 2
questo
scuola allora
questo gioco
la campagna offline
chiedo delle più belle che abbia mai
visto insieme al primo modello offre la
campagna uff line e' bellissima stupenda
ci ha una storia dell'isola l'unica
pecca è che dura
questa mi sembra tu intendi più belle
di quelle di un del primo modern warfre
però
e comunque poco per quanto e' bella
purtroppo buco si dovrebbe durare
all'infinito una storia incredibile
soprattutto la grafica di questo gioco
ma qual è il tuo pc gira siete invitati
si fa
anche se proprio
non a livelli stratosferici protestato
specifero a comporre musica
stupenda
che gestisce il tantissime cose su
schermo
easyjet leggi dispiace
io continuo a un computer della nasa un
poke da 19 anni mijo altino non
tantissimo
tutti i dettagli al massimo
in moto fluidi smettessero l'unica cosa
importante i giochi
perchè molto spesso fanno dei giochi
con una grafica target hip hop
ma se mass effect
consolgame non è in te
su console va bene
ma su pc io non l'ho preso su pc mass
effect
. c è anche su uno
sul mio computer bollenti spiriti
pesante ce
quando si stabilizza va bene ma quando
che ne so
scarica la mappa le coccinelle caricare
ancora alcuna rete alcune grafiche e del
livello
le texture della precarietà è un sacco
di roma perché si vede che è pesante
questo 1
parliamo sempre della componente online
due cose
da di vendola in puglia
e l'anno
lei emissioni in cooperativa che
purtroppo non sono riuscito ancora a
fare perché questo c'è un solaio tra
quelli tra le persone costo
questo ce l'ho solo io quindi
nonononono progettato come solo perchè
anche x honey 2 celle il geco predica
sarebbero mi sembra
due persone che devono affrontare un
annuncio sul 2
quindi basterebbe anche esposte motu
proprio computer pro più vecchio del
mio quindi ma molto più vecchio del mio
quindi non di parte
ma manco morire
fino all'anno non c'ho mai giocato
perchè passerebbe collaborazione anche
qui
con le cuffie eccetera parlarsi eheh
giocarci da solo non ha senso con il bot
l inter
l'altro è il online è normale
allora accendi una cosa tralasciando le
for the drum machine for vede che non è
la classica linea tutti contro tutti
e tecnici a squadre cattura la bandiera
cile per acqua
photo paint
down. late show pop i livelli
dopo aver giocato molto coperture
tutti gli altri giochionline
non mi piacciono più
brian tournament 3
chiami attori ci son cresciuto con la
tua parte stupendo
bellissimo
munari e' abbastanza carino però
dopo aver giocato modern warfre ripeto
questi giochetti in questo genere non
hanno più senso per me perchè
questo bellissimo q
onlinee
2 lo sparatutto online per eccellenza
per te
sale di livello
ci sono dei miti da sfatare
sblocchi garni sblocca visita
% sblocchi targhette sblocchi simboli
che poi all infinito anche solo pers
cettola giochi 5 minuti anche su questo
locale una tangente benissimo cecchino
voglio giocare tantissimo
ci sto giocando ci sto giocando a pian
piano non tantissimo ho anche altre cose
da fare.
ma soprattutto sali di livello è una
cosa importante
tra virgolette nel online
salire di livello 100 sei donna al non
ha molto senso giocare così giusto per
arrivare primo
e poi basta
per prima era così val di sole in modo
molto 2 secondo me queste sono opinioni
mia
non succede ovviamente molto più
divertenti giocarci con un clan
perchèèè coordinazione in me
4 e 5 tutti con le cuffie diverte può
esser diverte
ma anche se ci si gioca da soli non è
mai tanto della scuola e trovi sempre
una delle pecche più grandi di questo
gioco ecume fanno impostato online
non importava quando la prima volta mi
annoiano non apre 60 quando vado a casa
di mimici
camping la prima volta mi hanno fatto
giocare
all on line di halo 3 su xbox 360
ho visto cum erotici a cavi elettrici
cercare server in cui giocare
non era commento i classici giochi
cetty dalla lista di server il numero di
giocatori
lavate il nome dalla mappa sicilia
qualche modificazione
epicentro non c è il primo
inoltre erano
non ci sono server dedicati ce l'ho
server globali
she non c'è nessun tipo di partita
pulizia primo giocatore fa tutto lui
tu devi solo aspettare che trovi i
giocatori pessimista la partita
eh ma il cielo non piace però detto
questa credo sia l'impostazione da
console quindi
va bene io al pc
non non mi lamento
endomondo morte 2 fanno questa porcata
allucinante
i nomi dei server dedicati
anello scusate se mi sbaglio che non si
dice server dedicati ma
non me lo ricordo molto bene comunque
mi sembra di si non mettere server
dedicati
ho detto quella porta del server non
vuole
schifo perchè
se fa schifo da una parte perché
non puoi cavour serve il vostro
the descent of man gioco
l'hospice quello che rg tutta la partita
dire scelto dalla
da gioco taxi transfer per rubarle
non dai giocatori
quindi ogni tanto in tripartita ma non
si blocca tutto perchè il gioco sta
cambiando opposto crt mail aggrava ce
la sua connessione non era molto uù
non era molto stabile allora si giocava
maradona
in più di un gioco senza freezer ma non
si blocca gioco schermata dove ti dice
every che sarebbe sta cambiando lo
stregone - il libro karma is a bitch
davanti un miniconf ma mi è capitato un
sacco di volte
si aspetta molto ce io faccio
principalmente il tibet lecce il tin di
dati tecnici e altri che erano petinos
al differente richiedente merci elitè
cresce il tutti contro tutti in due
squadre
il team deathmatch veterano serie b
tutti contro tutti
ho due squadre però senza l'ausilio di
niente c'è un colpo in due
principalmente
senza pieno
senza radar senza niente
c'è realistico dei siti possibile
esperimenti facili faccio solo teen the
exciting etnici a veterano
clicchi per trovare una partita
prima ti devi cercare la partita di
ricerca loro buoni giocatori e aspetti
poi magari ti crea una sala d'attesa
c'è la sala d'attesa perché è una
partita con supporto ai giocatori non
puoi giocare solo con 4 giocatori
allora devi aspettare che magari atv
un'altra sala d'attesa con altri.
giocatori e mette insieme
decreto la partita
e devi scegliere c'è scelti casualmente
la moto acerra napoli città caso mente
vedere i giocatori possono
essi parla cinese prova a panda piace
molti giocatori possono dire saltatela
saltatela la saltini cambia mappa
però comunque aspetti
e qui si aspetta un bel po' tipo minuto
che non è tanto provo un minuto fermo
senza fare niente ad aspettare
youporno tour
aspè che sto periodo che va via cui
magari don omar alcuni giocatori se ne
vanno ella è la partita si resetta
perchè non ci sono abbastanza giocatore
e di nuovo cercare altre altezza
nell'attesa dormire
e aspetti
oddio o.o le sale d'attesa di un poco
resetta ogni minuto prima di giocare i
can down di un minuto
e aspetti
e aspetti tu sei già lì da tipo 10
minuti ancora non hai giocato
io di solito le partite di modo molte le
faccio perchè
ho 5 10 minuti
liberi quitting
3 minuti controllate a pacchetto può
finire
malesani anche dire do sto 10 minuti
avrò cura solo a far partire la partita
giochi giochi
8 sentenze in 5 4 3 hanno finalmente 2 1
palme fine estate
impossibile connettersi all'host
matura cariparma empoli giocare in 2
minuti la scelta di leonardo
non puoi toccare
oppure entri partita oppure ogni tanto
ti fa entrambe le partite 2 macro
212 sub alla fine c'è tuenti
se gazzi uccisioni zero morti ma finisce
la partita ma porca miseria
perchè
quinto perchè mi importa è che non sia
gestione di nulla
pac una cosa che mi son dimenticato
che ci stiamo don't work
siae nelle for the verde
stigma linkù books film
una delle più grandi cuochi di carta
avrebbero mai potuto fare
io lo so perchè hanno fatto stima
dalla pirateria c'è
e anche una roba tipo xbox line from a
proprio pc
tara in generale non prendetela l'aletta
tipo xbox vince tutto
aggiungi agli amici
effetti quando stanno giocando politica
nelle partite
case più cose
ma è un casino c'è
borgo e vorrei sapere da chi ce l'ha. ci
avete messo ad istallarlo questo. su pc
matita per colpa di stima per chi doveva
ti posso
caricarlo installarlo basti napoli
skynet fastidioso perchè
cerco di capire se il uno come me che
prima accusava
msn
scany port
x file includere aprirsi
testing an il gioco ci si impalla che
esplode in faccia computer d'opera
però dovuto togliere msn ho dovuto
togliere x file su temo solo sti
eeee [ __ ] suo ogni tanto a me non ha
mai dato problemi però hai risposto io
ogni tanto si apre
perchè si per primo con lettera
toccante di stile ogni tanto non si
connette perchè ci sono problemi
poi mentre stai giocando di scarica gli
aggiornamenti poi una volta dopo che
long
che lo aprite installa questi giorni di
un casino non si finisce mai pieno di
problemi
ed e una cosa fosse desire
fastidiosissimo apre lo so che lo hanno
fatto per la pirateria
perchè infatti modulo per due
scaricato non si può giocare online per
dire le for the ci si può giocare in
dei modi strani con garena golf a
spiegare perchè teoricamente illegale
ebay
noi è una faticaccia giocarci online
tanto vale comprarsi voce
questo è il muro dei pochissimi giochi
che ho comprato a prezzo pieno a tipo
quasi al lancio
c'era quasi in offerta non vi dicono
proporre perché tantissimo mi vergogno
perchè non spendere così tanti soldi
però quello nero ne vale la pena
effettivamente ce
questo è un mondo a parte il servizio
libri cavolo di server
ne vale la pena
o o ora parliamo di
word of worcraft il gioco
più amata turi e più odiato di tutti
c'è io sono uno di quelli che dicevano
un uomo a cui inviare un po' work
perché il gioco più bello del mondo
video
sono scelte
ceceni c'è chi dice che un uomo cattivo
gioco di merda
c'è chi dice uno hulka e la vita
non solo lo sfondo da una parte e
dall'altra perchè mi sembra esagerato
però
per me è molto porca chiediamo il i
giochi di ruolo
e un gioco di ruolo per eccellenza per
il gioco di ruolo per e zitta eccellenza
dopo diablo è il gioco, cui ha giocato
di più
da sud a sud sono fermato perchè anzi
ci siamo fermati con risposte perchè
non abbiamo più tu così tanto tempo.
per giocare quindi m
niente di ballo dell'esperienza ca.
allow to work at
anche questo
allora premetto io ho un giocatore
ha praticato in tilt. ti posso dire i
giochi di ruolo gratuiti che ci sono
i classici
intendevo rpg
che non è una malattia venerea
è un mmo rpg soli
i giochi online
puramente un lancio i giochi di ruolo
online che sarebbero ma nn vi è una
sigla pulire massico multiplayer honda
online è prorpio in inglese invece
migliori giochi di ruolo online ti passa
con loro
dicevo io ho giocato tutti giochi online
gratuiti
che fanno tutti
schifo
ma tutti cn che fanno schifo anche il
tuo cuore
ci sono sempre più giochicchia gli
argomenti ci mette un'ora ad arrivare
kodak il 20 alle 21 30 c. mesi
ricerca perchè sono tutti uguali si
combatte solo
soprattutto poi i personaggi se tu
vedere un gioco presente come metin2 che
escono le
secondo me sempre quindi
evitate di scrivo youtube
come pulire il pc per me metin2 uno dei
peggiori giochi
online ma infatti nella storia
dell'umanità
ci troverete un giocatore di livello
corrado giocatori di livello preso 60'
71 su neanche quale livello massimo
nello 60 su quali cioè
le armature sembrano identiche mi sembra
evidente destino fa schifo la shopper
io odio quando mi vuole mi sembra di
averlo già detto in bikini del gioco a
un gioco di ruolo perdite in or è un
personaggio salire di livello
le armature nuove uscite nuove armi
nuovi
kia usate
una volta effettuato dalla pizzata
lisa comodato prima fatto diablo 2
scusate diablo 2
indici gagliardi di amici erano e di
armature
all infinito
%
sono sola avete viste perchè ma di
scusa se si come faccio vedere
sono belle le cellule
tutti i posti da vedere in faccia delle
immagini
e felice ci sono miliardi di questa è
la cosa ho comprato delle cose più
importanti che
per salire livello ci metti
effettivamente tanti modulcasa ma ci
sono 8 miliardi di questa è la 20
miliardi
ma tu puoi fare quello che vuoi quasi
uomini
lamborgnini il cittadino giudici tatiana
questi pazienti gigantesco modo
gigantesco puoi
elenco l'espansione panico center prato
of the lich king
e impari cosiddetti crea una nuova isola
film uci gagliardo di altri oggetti
wrath of the lich king un'altra nuova
isola è un giga liable gli altri nuovi
getti quindi rossi balli di fila be sure
but uscire cataclisma la nuova
espansione non fosse la prendero'
perchè ho smesso di giocarci cardinale
la grafica simulcast effettivamente se
lavezzi si vede solo affitti richiama
picchia tra virgolette perchè io
mmm orari pc la grafica non è che serva
a molto
io io sono un pochetto
non so se avete visto il video di farenz
su youtube
io sono uno che come fare la spesa che
la grafica non è tutt
questo ne è la prova che il gioco che
tipo soggetti può tenere attaccato
tutta la vita
e senza mai annoiato e pure la grafica
non è così
stupefacente però a me piace un sacco
perchè
perchè leggerissima leggerissima
chi gestisce panoramiche enormi tutta
birra con lato oscuro dipende dalla zona
per sono tantissime zone
pieni di gente
più mi dimostri piedi questi piedi
oggetti
logistica per immissioni server va
benissimo
ha una cosa c'è molti criticano cd
misto molti video in cui veniva
criticato mutuo casa
ma per quale motivazione
chi ti cerca non lo comprerei mai un
gioco che ti crea assuefazione
q sanciti
cazzo vuol dire cioè
e' come dire
- lavaggio cioccolata perché mi
piacerebbe troppo
ma che ciò vuol dire cioè
non vuol dire niente se tu non puoi non
compra un gioco perchè
ti potrebbe tenere attaccato to fuck che
vul dire se non ha senso di esistere poi
ovvio
ci sono quelli che veramente
si schierano won't boot 80 a giocare 80
personaggio di milu massimo gennaro
mancinante che ci stanno tutta la vita
piroso
diciamo intermedio calcio giocato
d'anticipo capo spesso peloso riuscita a
fermare la neve sono impazzito
è un condotto in un grandissimo gioco
però
e comunque lo jogurt
non so possiamo quella linea della
realtà
niente quindi mi sento una cosa
assolutamente si salta al fatto che ti
crei associazione arci
è una cosa veloce
silvia burgio pene umano e dopo due
minuti che senso ha no io
adoro i giochi che creazzo sezione
diablo 2
era prove cmq perchè non lo fanno per
cellulare radio globo si mettevano
università lisbona metto un po'
una delle poche cose che mi manda in
bestia di who work
la gente con cui si gioca
tutti i server che ho provato
anche io lei
le risposte o
c'è un problema allora belli del mondo
almeno 80 che il massimo
non ci sono problemi tanto ce la
facciamo, risposta da soli ogni tanto ci
ha creato a qualcuno per fare qualche
missione e va bene
a level 80 si fanno le istanze che sale
stacey le stanze sono brutte di
giocatori
che banca.it angela luce un antimo
sapete cosa mangiare
badoo
io uccido tutti mossi fine arriva
harbours
giudice per potenziarsi il
le armature per cui fare man mano
istanze più potenti fino ad arrivare
distance più grandi di quelle con i pos
più
il problema è che
hyundai happy travel valentina beach
reso noto il la
versione italianizzata di tumblr
che la versione ristretta di niubbi
che sarebbe
colui che appena iniziato a giocare che
corregge
daniel una live rotante ci vogliono mesi
a volte per arrivarci
eppure lo dicono noi appena iniziato
giocate vale
il problema è che se noi siamo delle
debuttanti anche gli altri
purtroppo però censi come siamo dosser
verdi ci pensiamo uguale -
per chi ha vissuto a livello di armature
e di equipaggiamenti di armi
tu avevi collegare mature che hai
trovato nelle missioni occhio perchè si
è appena arrivato quindi teoricamente
dovresti fare i primissimi stanze con
giocatori del tuo stesso livello
perla aumentare
ce per aumentare il proprio
equipaggiamento
ovviamente no perchè io e stefano de
martino e risposta è ovvia moto
municipio
adele ad avere un personaggio sole rosso
primo personaggio che ha messo una vita
ad animare livello 80
l'ho ovviamente
tutte le altre persone al quarto quinto
giocatore che vi quarto quinto
personaggio che facevo
quindi e dicevano
re qui
mheetu primo passaggio si lol lol lol
alla potestà di gruppo con te nessuno
storico po' con noi
cagiva con quali regioni si chiamava la
mamma perché peso neonato carrefour
però è una cosa che ci faceva ti
incazzare perchè
io più che mai abbiamo pensato abbiamo
appena iniziato c'è
easybook material 80
vogliamo fare le distanze ci siamo
capiti apposta non per odio
alimentazione gatti anche per fare
istanza oppo guerra abbiamo mollato
gioco perché abbiamo fatti qualche
stanza
ma pochi pulsanti
si crea un gruppo deve crearsi radunarsi
ci vogliono in quanto dura 20 minuti
prima di farmi uscire a creare un gruppo
di gente per iniziare stanza
hey server crasha
qualcuno laggare pavia si disconnetterà
qualcuno gli cade la connessione si
disconette esiderya avere tutte udah
rottura veramente
soprattutto se non sei normale gita ci
sono su imvu con i giocatori
se sei da solo - 1 2
e' veramente tragico sei tutto tempo in
piazza a scrivere
convert from a scrivere chi c'è per
questi stanza vogliamo un guerriero
poliambulatorio bla bla bla e poi non si
arriva mai a fare niente perché nessuno
giudice per fare cosa
è la prima istanza dovranno essere
lambertucci
tutti vogliono fare le stanze più alte
dopo 18 anni
quando inizia così avete uscita in
entrambe le gilde nessuno ci voleva
dicevo cosa fate questo dai che lo
sapevamo quella porta
dvd che vediamo anche no sissi veniamo
anche noi abbiamo
&lt cosa si vede che è che chiude
matura siete
questo qui il nolano e te lo dice mamma
giochiamo
ma queste sono problemino si ripete un
problema che ho riscontrato io quindi ve
lo dico
io nn ho giocati molti dicevano che
alcuni a pagamento che però non mi
piacevano esempio di queste hey gioconda
ma i giochi con l
allora io scordata una grafica come mass
effect
pesantissima ma forse anche di più ma
proprio pesantissima batman non perché
i più dettagliata di quelle di mass
effect mai perché il fatto
non piget fatto diversamente
avon sistema grafico
troppo troppo pesante c'è troppo
pesante
un esempio di queste cose pratiche
se interrompo 2
se entro e' un gioco stupendo
è uscito per pc
qualcuno di voi ha provato la versione
per pc mi si intromette impossibile da
giocare in possibile
a livello di dettaglio un minimo che non
ha una grafica tutta nuda allucinante si
è buona ma come allucinante
party aska teacher gta 4 livello vedo mi
partiva bene se entro 2 parte marisa
questo perché
cisti scuola materna grafica questo che
un gioco di ruolo online ce dove ci sono
moltissimi giocatori
mutuo e una faticaccia ci vediamo quando
carica devi aspettare che
vedo su tutta la grafica tutti i colori
perchè stupri giovedì all'inizio
emanata giglio
ehm
vedere questo ruolo paga con la bellezza
di un lemure 99
circa 39 euro e 90 unieuro a d'amore
&lt di solito non pago per giocare
era il giorno e mi da fastidio pagare
per giocare ai giochi
perchè japan-guide internet e pago
gioco in cui far pagare anche l'inter
protesi
sono con sono così via
usiamo questo cuore per woolworth e
altre cose vengono le carte prepagate da
60 giorni
se avete fatto le tenevo per l'equivoco
world mixer ma così non 26 euro sito
web 2 mesi 26 euro
sapete quanto costano le carte prepagate
tv il gioco numero quattro libro dal
pino scotto
costano la bellezza di un euro 99 ogni
carta quindi ho preso
38 parte levopraid ora ho preso il tuo 3
giusto per provare il gioco
ho provato a video su berna
3 ore 3 4 ora quello assolutamente
mollato perchè
ce la facevo ci metterò trucco poi
eurosport euro come modem router le
cimici giochi 5 minuti polopoly
ci si può anche giocare cinese
come va bene perticolarmente dire de
valera - oppure muore per giocare a una
hai giù qualche foto 4
roberto bolle hot
io poi
personalmente sono un patito delle guide
strategiche mi piace un sacco anche i
videogiochi che non ho
l'incubo perché sono bellissimi mi
disegni di art book lema per il
emissioni ce
mi piace un sacco
eloro detto book celi solito non le
compro le compro quando obliviscendum a
4 euro e 90 massimo roma eur e 90
ora sono la tua testo da dove compra una
carta prepagata
e ho visto c'era la guida tv
hey joe scuola bellissima classical
guitar che
dopo il dopo la prima volta espansione
gratuita
era completamente inutile perchè
mancava un sacco di dimissioni o sacco
di marte ci provi con quello presa
perchè mi piace
mi piace un sacco sfogliare queste cose
quindi se invece capra
solo per vendetta chissà quanto costo
secondo voi una guida strategica che
bobine costano 20 euro
20 15 euro 10 euro quando scalano
quattro alla volta quando fanno le
offerte massimo
secondo voi questa foto l'ho pagata
20 euro
10 buone
5 nono non apri contattaci pertanto mi
serviva
no perchè domani veduto prende la tre
mi potevo perdermi un panino con 3 1
un euro
no troppo 50 centesimi -
trenta sicli
10 centesimi
5 centesimi
gioco
tre centimetri no
delussu romanzi vado a prenderlo
scontrino più opportuna bacchettone.
immagini telefilm è un fucile tra
oh happy su onlus. comprato una guida
strategica di un gioco
aucun sintesi love giusto se fai pagare
il gioco
unieuro 99 la guida cella guidate di
scalare in base al prezzo di costo
cuccette rivolta sul web non so se
riuscite elettrici scritto
ho creduto guida e il suo
con matteo gioconda
total euro
0 , 0 1
contate e io doppio zero, si cucinano
anche da
felicidad
quindi secondo me lo sono inventato un
centesimo una guida strategica
è impazzito quel giorno vorrei dire una
cosa e poi chiudo con i videogiochi
questo è una cosa generale inside joke
ma soprattutto si ride giochino
agevolazione presepio
crediamo modern warfer 2
custodia normalissima
è normale
manuale cervice calde coppie sottile
manuale se non sapete cosa serve ti
spiega
solite cose cuneo
nel me installare il gioco bocce a quale
2010 ti stimo come installare gioco i
tasti
ti spiegherò con procura
paginetta di
d link informazioni del
della schermata di quando giochi cilmi
vino bricofer in bianco e nero ep 4 ma
non mi ha anche preso immagini di gioco
ce lo scrivo qua il grigio non è
perchè voi non riuscite a vedere
e' proprio grigio
qualche informazione su minore quelle
classiche cose che fb spa attenzione a
non bagnare di sketch effect solo 4
pagine
60 euro per un gioco ci sono quattro
pagine di manuale
pregnant nude for peta
apro le fucked
tvb codice per istallare gioco è niente
male ma non perchè me l'hanno venduto
usato nuovo preso nuovo
non c'è manuale
io odio i giochi nuovi
perchè non vedi mettere il manuale del
doping
dentro la custode del gioko
tupac in gioco 60 euro dentro ci deve
essere tutto secondo me c'è una cosa
nella confezione
e' come quando ti faccio un regalo se
loro sicuro ti regala pietro conatti
tico tacos itc tieni questo è il regalo
così contento perché i genitori
giocone ma da una parte dal buio della
potestà tizio
peccato però che non era confezionato
bene
certissimo confeziona per un regalo con
la carte tutori legali ancora più bello
anche se cade sempre lo stesso però il
regalo della cosa ti stimo molto più
veloce il la carta scartarlo il
bigliettino con scritto gli auguri per
pc
ed. che bello
stessa cosa del gioco si è spento
non è questo caldo direttore di genova
60 euro per un gioco elenco non c'è
assolutamente nulla oltre il dvd di
gioco
incasso un pò
ma un po'
ma perchè
perchè io parlo dei giochi
quelli vecchi c'è accordi o no il primo
uomo tua cartella custode quegli occhi
la5 xd
è un po' scomodo effettivamente però
5 siti web
prof guardate cosa ce l'ha detto
oltre ciao un catalogo dei prodotti
nella vita
il manuale
guardate quote spesso fa male c'è un
libro re
università e si è lamentata per questo
iphone no comment libro come formattare
pc da ce
storie di qualsiasi cosa schermate di
personaggi
essi in una ragazza per tutti i miei
parco di patty addirittura levante
del gioco il capo e nero e ma perchè
facebook c'avevo
per la prostituta che si trasformano
alcune ore
carlo studio di qualsiasi cosa classi
razze c tutto io le adoro queste cose
con codice
del gioco -
in queste cose impazzisco quando vedo
delle cose così e' pieno pieno pieno
pieno di roma
a me piacciono queste cose non vedo
perchè non vedo non fai più
i fatti degli altri
in quelli nuovi c'è il video di denti
dvd di gioco
poi mammole tutte colissimo devi
spiegare classiche cose come istallare
gioco le cose che odio ti odio ti odio
queste cose
ma presepio
ho comprato ho pochissimo ma proprio
pochissimo prezzo non so perchè stanno
impazzendo
lecce compro tutto a pochissimo prezzo
perchè
nei negozi dicono che gamestop o detto
ma scusate quagliarella la guida di
gioco nel sito impazziti costa un
centesimo mai avere fascisti è vero
the per pc nessuno + compralo all'asta
poste vendo tutto
merda mare
boh per me ma male perchè poi non ci
vanno più esclusive per pc marocco
questo pacchetto pochissime la black box
della via della sigla eidos non ci sono
nuovi giochi dentro me
petite robe nero sono stati parecchi di
questi fate
cheese calcetto
crisi taxi c'è tomb raider che fa
schifo photobomber cerca e me capì
fecero auto travolge un gran bel gioco
commandos 3 cambiando il gioco the sims
deluxe egli desidera
per battelfield vietnam
mosse volte di chi è bellissima e
pacifico assolte non medal of honor
pacific assault volte
io mi son chiesto
come si fa a stare delle custode del
genere
perchè secondo voi questo ci potrebbe
stare
in un uomo solo mettendomi giochi
pur crema di buste certo
2 agosto comprare una scatola con un
giochi così
c'è tanto vale che badoo
la bancarella di
qualcuno di alda catone live oppure
faccio comprare masterizzata betshop
erbe
poi certo
ma devo portare la sua del 900
parte che non c'è nessun poggetto
dentro i codici dei giochi software
sulla scatola sulla scatola direttamente
all'interno della scatola
la turchia dentro l'altra
ma non tutte le tope
beh e va be'
la questo l'hanno fatto per problemi di
spazio mettere la la carta
many man man ci stavano. sapete cosa ho
fatto a letto
manuale di questi giochi c'erano tutti
ma non lasciamoci tale che dice cosa che
ho fatto
un dvd con scritto the better box e dice
un pc collection manuale ma dove vai
non so parlar d'altro e dintorni
scaricato anche questa è vita in che
senso ha fare un cd corrimano argomenti
le ho mai detto di riposo legge che
manuale manu
ambiente se lo devo leggere dvd che
senso fa
tanto non so se un solo problema mio ma
questi giochi
quando installo
mi dice poi inserire dvd cornetto quindi
io potevo scaricare la crack
metterla nel un gioco originale perchè
non so perchè forse perché sono vecchi
ma non così tanto ci sono tutti
compatibili con wii speak
quando io li metto lista o gruppo non
posso giocarci con questo tipo di donne
che si apra
tanto vale che me li compro masterizzati
che problema è questo
io ho finito
scusatemi se di dove era molto lungo
perdonatemi se volete con la funzione
undo importante
e scusate se i super veloce nonostante
sia abbastanza busty super veloce per
fiere
non ho tempo di montalcino tutto non ho
trovato immagini
e quindi niente sky si vede alla un
premiazione del
del concorso
sono felice di fare nuovo già fatto la
lista petrovafire la lista dei
possibili candidati alla finale sono
13 gennaio su come scegliere un pub e ne
parlero' polpette
siete tutti sullo stesso livello
quindi dovrai scegliere delle
motivazioni stupide per torte vince per
decretare il vincitore dove siete delle
votazioni
superato degli altri però mi spiace. ne
parlerò cui al concorso ci siete il 20
marzo